hey what's up this is
[Music]
we've received word that a Los
angeles-based musician has been
kidnapped victim's name is Kat Odin
she's an Australian musician
detective Dobson right yes sir I might
see you earlier than this if you can't
solve this crime before some jack off on
the internet does then you can kiss your
job goodbye
oh man what are you people doing here
I'm not going on the record today we're
joined via satellite by Andrea and Jack
Oden I am not saying we should not
listen to her side of the story there's
still no word from the abductor from the
abductee from no one
[Music]
started
I did it again
[Music]
thank you